Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab and we're back.
Now I'm going to take you back live on
stage at the Brooklyn Academy of Music.
And this next story you'll hear
some references to some pictures,
which obviously you won't be able to see,
but we've got them for
you@radiolab.org um,
so we wanna finish the night with a
salute to a guy who's been on our program
and part of our family pretty
much from the beginning.
I have known him for more than 35 years.
Early on when radio lab started,
I asked him if he'd help us out
and send us a few story ideas.
He didn't send us a few. He sent us
bushels, tales of chemistry and medicine,
hallucinations, music people,
so many extraordinary people that he
knew or found or help cause the guy just
doesn't run out. Dr. Oliver Sacks,
your honor, [inaudible]
is a guy who noticed it.
Everything is deeply interested in
everything that happens around him and to
him.
And tonight we're bringing them back
on tape for what lasts may be his final
offering for us. As many of you know,
Dr Sachs recently was diagnosed with liver
cancer and he wrote about this in the
New York Times. He said he plans to spend
the time that he has a left writing,
being with friends, not doing interviews,
but he did agree to share his
thoughts exclusively with,
with us tonight for you gathered here.
Um, cause he's one of our family.
So as I've done for decades now,
I went over to his house in Manhattan
with my mic and I said to him,
I just need to know what, what just
happened a month and a half ago.
You were fine. And then what? Um,
at the beginning of the year I was fine.
On the 3rd of January I felt a little
queer and I pass some dark urine.
I thought I had a little
gallbladder attack and um,
didn't pay that much attention,
but thought I better get
things checked. And um,
the extra which was expected. Ou
need to show a couple of gallstones,
showed hundreds of cysts in my liver.
Uh, although my doctor said he
didn't know what the, here's one,
I would need further tests.
I, I knew what they were.
I said it's happened.
And he was right.
The doctors eventually confirmed that
a cancer that had been found in his eye
nine years ago had spread
to his liver. Where you
frightened or relieved or console or what,
what? No, I am,
I think my first feeling was
one of, of overwhelming sadness.
Um, now all sorts of
things I won't see. Um,
and I won't do one or two people
have written to me in the, you know,
consoling me and said, well, you
know, we all die, but fuck it.
It's not like we all die. It's
like you have four months.
Has that, has your PR, what is
your prognosis at this moment?
Cause I know you had an [inaudible]
well, it, it gets revised.
It depends of course,
on how the cancer responds to treatments
and or how quickly it spreads so far.
Um, the metasticies from
my eye, only in my liver,
I'm told they love liver.
Actually, I love liver as well.
And one of the magical
things I did was to go and,
and have lived one Allianz
sued after the doctors
and thinking that liberal looks better
than mine. He, this is what he's like,
instead of being frightened by the
thing that's trying to kill him,
he's thinking about loving liver and
liver lovers and looking for connections
and wondering if he doesn't stop. He,
he just notices that the case in point a
few months ago, his doctor said to him,
we're going to run a line up your liver
and in effect we're going to try to
shave off or starve some of the
cancer cells first on one side,
then on the other to see if we
can give you a little more time.
But they weren't him
as the metasticies die.
They put out various unpleasant
chemicals that may exhaust you,
tax your system badly.
And um, at one point,
shortly after the procedures,
I started talking a little
strangely and um, as I was talking,
I was also writing, um,
you will be the first person to see this.
So he showed me a notebook and were
showing it to you in just a moment.
You can see they're sort of
writing there on the left.
It's all he's writing a book,
actually a children's book about the
elementary table, but as he was writing,
if you, if you look to the next page,
if you can see that it gets a little
bit wobbly, the letters and then,
and then there was some crossing
out there. Yes, I see it.
And then rather dramatically the
lighting changes it actually there's,
there's a large slash
across it and then you,
it seems a little incoherent
and the partners, okay.
And then it turns to pure scribble
that has delirium and crept up on me.
All this happened over the course of 10
minutes and I see what he's doing here.
He's figuring, okay, I'm
writing at a constant speed.
I know pretty much how fast I,
right. And so I can time this out.
I can figure out exactly how long it took
me to slip into delirium and then out
of this delirium and he's
doing this very, very sick man.
It's science to write it
out in a more medical way.
I think this would form
a lovely illustration.
You put in a timeline of
delirium just coming like that.
Why aren't you more frantic?
Unusual for any doctor
and a man of science.
You don't seem to worry at all when
things become incoherent or strange.
You're now showing it to me as
if like, Ooh how interesting.
I was crazy here for a little bit. Um,
the truth is Oliver is fascinated by
what goes on in the human mind no matter
how strange he gets up there
at one time when he was a young
resident in California driving his bike.
And by the way,
I should show you what he looked like
back then when he was driving his bike.
This I think is him in New
York. Uh, Kinda, you know,
in the 60s he was also a champion
weightlifter. They called him Dr Squat.
And in this picture
that you show you here,
that's him raising 600 pounds in order
to win a trophy. Like, this is a,
the, he was a champ and,
and you can see more pictures like these
cause we have signed copies of Oliver's
new memoir out for sale in the lobby.
It's pretty good book too by the way.
So in any case at this
time, and then 1960s,
in addition to being all muscled out,
Oliver was a serious recreational
drug taker. And because he's Oliver,
he was extremely curious about his
highs no matter how weird they were.
One time for example, he took 20
pills that he shouldn't have. And then
to my surprise, um, uh,
there was a spider on the
wall which said hello.
It had a voice like and famous
mathematician and it, um,
it asked me a lot of the
technical question as to
where the Russell had exploded
for egos paradox. And, um,
we had this conversation
answered the spider,
I'm sure I onto the spine discussed
fragrance paradox with this minor.
I didn't deed Chris, you, you
trust your perceptions. Okay.
Many years later when I mentioned this
to an entomologist friend of Cornell and
the philosophical spider, he said,
yes. He said, I know the species.
So thinking Oliver's way, taking it
all in, talking spiders, whatever.
The generosity of his
curiosity becomes profound.
The moving and transformative
when he's treating his patients.
I want to tell one story here really
quickly to, to demonstrate what I mean.
Oliver once had a patient
whom he called Mrs o c
she was an old woman.
She was 88 years old,
living in a nursing home and
one night she was awakened,
jarred awake by a loud sound.
Um,
it was a song
[inaudible]
and she thought, well, somebody's left
the radio on, but when she looked,
the media in the room was off,
her roommate sound asleep,
which was odd because the song
was really loud. Good. Doris.
After that, there was another song.
Ah,
and then another song is a home.
Great. Mrs [inaudible] thought,
well, maybe my roommate can't hear
the songs because the songs are,
are coming through the fillings in my
teeth. I've heard that's possible. But no,
her doctors told her, this
is something in your head.
You need to see a neurologist,
which led her to Dr Sachs.
Now. When he met Mrs Ossi, he,
she could barely hear the song sung by
the female voice were coming and coming.
She was frightened and justifiably
worried that she was going crazy,
but Oliver said, no, no, no, I'm going
to do some tests. And when he was done,
he said he'd found a slight stroke or
condition that had triggered musical
epilepsy. These sudden
production of music in her brain.
Now a normal doctor might say,
okay, we've got the diagnosis,
and he thought that the songs would
probably fade and it will pass,
so they would be done. But Oliver
did not stop. He doesn't stop
[inaudible]
he kept talking to her.
She told him she was born in Ireland in
the 1890s her father died before she was
born. Her mother, when she was only five
often alone,
she was sent to America to live
for the welder for beating maiden.
She had no conscious memory as
the first five years of her life,
no memory of her mother of Ireland.
She had always felt this as
a key in and painful sadness,
this lack or forgetting of the earliest,
most precious years of her life.
So we asked her about the songs, what
are they like? And Mrs [inaudible] said,
well, I think they're lullabies.
Can you sing them for me? She did.
And then after checking with,
I'm not sure who Oliver figured out that
these songs were happened to be popular
Irish ballads from the 1890s
when Mrs OSI was a little baby.
And that gave him an idea. Now
what he does next isn't science.
It isn't in any traditional way medicine.
He just told her a story
and it goes like this.
You know how nobody remembers anything
that happens to you when you're one or
two or three? Well, there was a
theory once, not honored much today,
but it's sad that those earliest
memories get locked away,
deepen our brains in a special
safe that we can never open.
So let's suppose Mrs o c your stroke
by some crazy chance open the lock that
none of us can break and release those
first memories in you just for a little
while. So that the voice
you're listening to,
there's at home by grade a, then Mo,
maybe that isn't a radio voice. Let's
say that it's your mother's voice.
That's your missing mother.
And so at the ripe old age of 88 you
finally get to be back in your mother's
arms. You get to be a baby again.
And Mrs [inaudible] thought
about that and said, okay,
it sort of fits.
I'm an old woman with a stroke
in an old people's home,
but I feel I'm a child to Kyle on the
gate. I feel my mother's arms. I see her,
I hear her voice soon,
the green, it clean.
Who's around run, sweetie.
Shortly thereafter, the songs
began to fade. The pauses widened.
Mrs OSI had been so frightened by this
music in her head was now sorry to see
the songs go. But it was Oliver who
noticed how those songs had touched her,
who noticed that the songs might become
a comfort to her because that's what he
does. He listens closely. He
can hear another person's heart.
And this is really the profound puzzle
for me of Oliver because reading the new
autobiography,
you see that while he was so full of
heart as a doctor in his own life and in
the relationships that really mattered,
it turns out he didn't get a whole lot
of affection. He was for a long time,
a lonely guy.
I'd say he was very lonely and he's
talking about that now for the first time.
Let me, let me talk about
love for a minute. Um,
in this book you tell the story of your,
of your very first love a fellow
by the name of Richard Selleck.
Can you just tell me that
what happened with him? Um, yeah. Um,
he was a road scholar at Oxford and I'm
a poet and handsome and beautiful beyond
belief and I sort of fell for him. Um,
although I didn't say
anything because I was um, uh,
very haunted by my mother's
accusations. What did your mother,
um,
well to go a couple of years back then
my father had opened a conversation,
I was about to go to Oxford and have
sort of father son conversation.
And he said, um, we don't seem to
have many girlfriends. And I said,
no, wishing the conversation
would stop. He said, um,
something wrong with girls. And
I said, no, that they're fine.
Perhaps you prefer boys. And I
said, well, yes I do. I said,
I've never done anything, but I do.
And then you knew that then I knew
that. Then I'd known it for six years,
probably since I was 12. Um, and I said,
don't tell mom she will
be able to take it.
But my father did tell my mother and
the night and the next morning she came
down with them.
I somehow want to say a face
of funder and raged at me.
And among other things
said, you're an abomination.
I wish you had never been born.
And then she suddenly shut up
and said nothing for three days.
And, um, uh,
the matter was never mentioned
again in her lifetime.
And then two years later I found myself
for the first time in my life falling in
love.
This was the gun guy, Richard
Oliver at the time was in college.
It was a very positive feeling though.
I didn't know whether it was one,
which I did express, but I did say,
so with my heart and my mouth
to Richard, what did you,
you remember what you said? Uh, I
said, I'm in love with you, Huh.
And, uh, Richard gripped me
by the shoulders and he said,
I know he said, but I'm not that way,
but I love you in my own. And um,
I was glad I had said that I'm glad that
it had been received in such a warm,
friendly way. I thought we might be
friends for the rest of our lives,
but then one day he came into me,
he said he'd been bothered by finding
a lump in his groin and he was worried
could I have a look at it?
And I looked at it and I felt
it and it was hard and tethered,
uh, turned out to be a,
a particularly malignant
form of lymphoid to my,
what was called the
lympho sarcoma. And, um,
he never spoke to me again after that.
I don't know whether since I'd been the
first to recognize the ominous import,
I don't know whether he saw me as a
harbinger of death or messenger of death,
whatever. But you were left with
the, with that silence. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
A few years later, Oliver met and man
named Mel, he was young, he was a sailor.
He like Oliver, he was into weightlifting,
they became close friends and
they began living together.
I adored him and was in love with him
and loved physical contact with him
and they'd work out and they'd wrestle
and ride motorcycles kind of tightly.
And they never talked about what might
or might not be happening between them.
But one day they were together and
Oliver was giving mil a back massage,
which mill often asked him to do.
And uh, I love doing that. And Oliver
says sometimes he'd get a little,
you know, excited.
And so long as I gave no explicit
indication it was okay but, but,
but one day things went a bit
too far and I got sort of um,
I went over the bridge instead of just
before the big metal immediately sort of
got up and had a shower and said, I,
I can't stay with you anymore. And um,
I found that very cruel and upsetting
and heartbreaking and it made me feel I
don't want to have anything to do with
people. I must have fallen in love.
I cannot share life's with anyone again.
And he didn't share his life with
anyone for a long, long. Yeah.
In fact,
he told me a story about something that
happened to him maybe eight years ago.
I was just joining the faculty at Columbia
and I was having this interview and
at one point the interviewer
said to me, she said,
I have something whether private
to our school, we do like Ms Edgar,
your system to leave. And I said,
no, she's privy to all my affairs.
And I then sent thinking she was
going to ask me about six. I said,
I haven't had any sex for 35 years.
I bet in fact what she was going
to ask me, my social security
and she burst into laughter. She said,
Oh, you poor with this. She said,
we must do something about it.
Well, the truth is Oliver,
I didn't do about it because he didn't
think he could. I mean he chosen,
Richard Lost, Richard Chosen, Mel lost.
Now it wasn't the point he was thinking.
And then finally, and who knows when
or why these things happen to people.
But a man came along who for
the first time chose Oliver.
I have met Billy is I meet a number of
people because I'd been sent a manuscript
or proof for book and um,
intimacy grew between us.
I don't think I quite
realized how deep it was.
But then there was a particular episode
in Christmas of Oh nine when he came up
and in a sort of serious way,
he has a serious careful way. He said, I,
I have conceived a deep love for you.
I have conceived a deep
love for you. Yeah. Um,
there is a trait that's like, got
a few extra words I have concealed.
Okay. Was He scared to
say I love you or um, no,
he likes the English language.
[inaudible]
I think it, I think it
couldn't have been put, um,
more cautiously and yet more strongly.
I think it was a beautiful
way of putting it.
And then I realized at that
moment with his saying that,
that I had conceived a deep love
for him and I am among other things.
I thought, good God, it's happened again.
Two
and I'm in my 77th year and um, and,
and what next
and the things, um,
basically have gone happily ever since
[inaudible]
and surprisingly look loosely. Um,
because then again, I'm
not dealing with, oh,
what I'm dealing with or who
I'm dealing with an individual.
I'm not dealing with a, um, uh,
a condition defined by medicine or law.
So Oliver's still doesn't know how much
time he has left. But for the moment,
as you can hear, his mind is
totally intact. He's still writing.
He has two books in addition to the one
you'll find in the lobby B that he's
writing. Then the children's book,
bunch of New Yorkers stories in the last
few months and in New York review of
books story, he's got energy to spare.
So I want to do one last thing before
we close and this comes from yet.
Another conversation I had with him,
and it's a story I know Oliver would hate
because he's not a capital r religious
kind of guy,
but he is somebody who definitely embraces
mystery and for a long time he's been
mystified by a color
called indigo, indigo,
which hadn't suited
between blue and violet and no,
no two people seem to agree
as to what indigo was like.
And so I built up a sort
of chemical launchpad,
meaning he took a lot of
base of amphetamine from general a while,
so then some assets and a little cannabis,
and when I was sufficiently
stoned I said I want to see
the indigo now
[inaudible]
as if it were reply and does
it phone by giant paintbrush.
That appeared a huge trembling,
pear shaped blob of what I instantly
realized was pure indigo on the white wall
in front of me. It had had
a wonderful luminosity,
and in particular I am, although
I am not a religious person,
I thought this is the color of heaven.
And I lit towards it in a sort of ecstasy
and then suddenly disappeared. And he
says he had one more moment like that.
This time, no drugs. He was in a
museum staring at an Egyptian artifact.
He sees this re and color
back again just for a beat.
I was given five tantalizing
seconds of, of, of radiant,
ineffable
beauty. And then again, it vanished.
And that was in 1965 and
I've never seen indigo since.
But who knows? You know,
someday I like to think Dr Sachs
may get to see that color again.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that was the remarkable Sarah lip
state also calls herself novella.
That was her own composition.
[inaudible] special thanks also to Josh
Higginson and Keith scratch who, uh,
mounted this whole show with no
time and extraordinary ingenuity.
Yeah. And certainly a huge, huge,
huge thanks to Ellen Horne who
carried the load on this thing. Man.
You Mickey capper and Kate Edgar,
Ben Cohen and Nadia Sirota.
Everybody at band, especially Nick
Schwartz Hall, Barbara Wall Steam Test,
James and all the folks that, so
percussion. Eric, Chubby, Jason,
Troy Adams Lewinsky, uh, Josh Quillin.
Special thanks to Thomas Shira,
she's the production manager production.
Thanks also to Wny C's
recording engineers, Edward
Haber, George Wellington,
and Noriko Okabe. And
thanks also to Eva Dasher.
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.